I don't need to go through Chris's phone
I don't need to sniff his underwear I
don't need to you know do all these
things that Ashley has admitted to us
that she's had to do with her now almost
ex-husband you trust your husband I
trust
there was a situation in which Chris
made me feel completely uncomfortable do
you feel like it was a premeditated
attack on you I don't know it feels
gross it feels icky and it feels
disingenuous to our show and what our
show stands for which is friendship and
family and reality not scripted my
husband is now the target if you want
that Michael Darby is available for that
the ass grabbing [ __ ] that likes
to actually make people feel
uncomfortable he's available for that
not my husband why are we at a place
where we feel like we need to make
things up and make things up that really
challenge an entire metoo movement it
sets women back so far to use a platform
like this to
to lie or embellish or create drama
where there should be none how much did
this season challenge your marriage on a
scale of one to ten I would say
150. it's been challenging not in a way
that broke my husband and I apart but
challenging in a way that
forced us to to have to come together
just seeing my husband
be bewildered and just astonished by
such heinous accusations
all for entertainment
has been really hurtful if there was
some truth to what was being said
I would absolutely call him on and I
would absolutely hold him accountable
too flirty or just friendly can't
distiller bassett's husband is at the
center of major drama on the Real
Housewives of Potomac with both Gisele
Bryant and Ashley Darby calling him out
for some questionable Behavior we sat
down with Candace at the Baja mar Resort
where she shut down their claims I don't
ever want to be in a bedroom with a
married man yeah I'm just going to take
my black ass and get out because the
alternative is Gisele gets the ratata
one I don't need the camera that was a
fight or flight moment for me that was
my reality in that moment I had to go I
had to get out of there because I saw I
saw the the bad acting it was like a bad
Broadway show that two people bought
tickets to and I I couldn't sit there
anymore I got things to do and to lose
not today Satan
not today Nick
not today ankles so I'm gonna get in
trouble for body shaming yet again I'm
sorry to the necks and ankles of the
world it just dropped in my lap people
often ask me do you like write these
things down and it's no I'm literally
sitting in the chair much like I am
right now and you know the the shade
assassin comes down and sits on my
shoulder
and just handles it so last night I get
this damn from Chris at 2 42 he writes
you should have came to the W I know
Candace wasn't there you and Ashley
seemed like you were on the road back to
a friendship why do you think the two of
you just can't get to that place at this
point I'm just I'm gonna go on record as
saying it's not me it's her I have tried
and tried again I invited her into my
home I've just decided that Ashley for
whatever reason she can't take me I
agitate something in her and it creates
this this me this passion for throwing
darts at the Candice board and you know
so I'm I'm bobbing and weaving
in Potomac okay
likes to leave you do you want to go to
a man named house
and oh Chris
[Music]
you brought out this escort comment why
go there it was not my finest moment I
will I will say that
um I
I felt like we were in this place again
where
we we break up as friends we have our
beef and then we make up and she looks
me in the eye and there's this honest
effort I'm thinking from her to to be
friends and then the moment that you
need a moment you are back to
try lying and trying to malign my
husband in a very damaging way so you
know I as I always say you bring
grenades to the party I bring rocket
launchers so then a potential season
eight what does that then look like for
the two of you to operate within this
friend group I have no idea and I think
it really depends on her at this point
I'm I am where I am right is right and
wrong is wrong and if if she can get to
a place where she can own what she has
created of her own volition for
entertainment purposes then maybe I
could get to a place where
I respect her again but Candace isn't
the only housewife throw it down on the
Bravo show Sunday night
you did miss the mess in Miami with your
co-stars Miami was a cluster a cluster
leap and I'm happy that for once Candace
was not in the mess when you got
downloaded on everything that went down
what did you make of that my mouth was a
gape my mouth was on the floor I'm just
how are we back here how are we back in
this place where we just can't use our
words children re the library is always
open read a book yes Housewives assigned
and the 35 year old is also making a
name for herself in music she not only
has a new single insecure
[Music]
but she also kicked off a live concert
series at the SLS Sky Bar and secure is
lonely what does this moment mean to you
as an artist this is my first real
International performance so I'm just
I'm like trying to stay in the moment
and take it all in people will stop me
and I'm thinking they're stopping me
because oh they watch Potomac Housewives
which is an amazing platform but to know
that they only know me as Candace drive
back drive back here are we coming yes
that they know and they'll sing the
songs to me it that is that's a new
level of just ego boost and reassurance
what are Candace's insecurities do you
even have any oh my God uh I yes I am a
Confident Woman I'm I'm a
self-actualized woman I'm sure of who I
am but I definitely have moments where
I'm like am I doing the right thing are
my eyebrows on straight
um like
is my bunion sticking out of my shoe
like there are definitely things about
me that I have had to to learn to grow
and love and look in the mirror and tell
myself you are enough and you're good
enough as you set the groundwork for
this next chapter what is on the musical
career bucket list still I've been
saying that I want to do more features
in my music I love little Nas X so this
is like my cry on E.T straight to the
camera little Nas hey come come meet me
at the SLS in the Bahamas let's do a
song so if you have to
it comes to a point where there's
acting music Housewives and one has to
go what falls off well you know for as
long as I can ride the housewives ride I
will be here you know I'm gonna have
myself my moisturized self on the scene
[Music]